hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Game of Thrones catch-up
video before season six so what I'm
gonna do is go around the map of the
world and talk about all the big
storylines where we left off and where
they're headed based on what we know
from the trailer so let's start north of
the wall and we'll work our way around
the map counterclockwise will go through
Westeros first and then we'll go through
the eastern storylines so just careful
for spoilers for everything that's
happened on the show so far and we'll be
talking about stuff that happens in the
trailer so starting up way near hardhome
here this is the last place that we saw
the night's king in his army they're
just going around grabbing all the
wildlings they can adding to their army
so if there's a dead body to be had they
are adding it to their army over here is
brands where would the last time we saw
him at the end of season 4 he was
climbing underneath meeting the
three-eyed raven and learning about what
it is to be a green seer it really is
from a practical standpoint a lot like
Jedi powers but he's actually going to
be one of the most powerful people on
the show this year there'll be all kinds
of crazy visual effects a lot of the
exposition that we would get in
prologues epilogues will probably see
through his eyes I like to think that
the Tower of joy flashback is a little
more hopeful but that kind of gets into
spoilers so we could talk about it when
we actually see it and just to clarify
the actual Tower of joy is way down here
in Dorne so if we're gonna be singing
through brains eyes that gives you an
idea for the scope of his power moving a
little further south to the wall at the
end of last season we saw the Nights
Watch revolt against Jon Snow stab the
[ __ ] out of him in the trailer we see
that he's a corpsicle so it seems like
he's gonna be riding the bench for a
little while till he comes back
we don't really know how that's gonna
happen but there are a lot of theories
one that he's gonna come back through
some form of fire to that MELAS Andrews
gonna bring him back even if you haven't
been a book reader you've probably heard
theories about how Jon Snow is going to
come back so it's gonna be a lot of fun
to see how they actually pull it off
they have said that season six is going
off book because wins a winner is
arguably the book that's going to bring
Jon Snow back so we don't know how
George RR Martin's gonna do it exactly
but Dan and Dave have said that they
have a pretty good idea for where all
the characters are headed like where the
plot is headed without explicitly having
read all of the winds of winter stuff
that's been completed so far so largely
all the storylines I think they're doing
are going to be pretty close to the book
it just a lot of characters will be
swapped out and they'll be characters
like Brienne for instance that will be
featured more on the show than they are
in the books but now the surviving
Nights Watch led by
thorn is trying to burn Jon Snow's body
The Onion Knight Melisandre and their
supporters there are a couple of knights
watch that still support Jon Snow are
trying to keep them from doing that so
that's gonna be the big conflict in
Episode one do not burn this body until
coach puts them back in the game we also
have the wild Lynx they're a little
further south they've already come
through the gate so there's south of the
wall now but one the people the Nights
Watch really hate them they want to get
rid of them you go further south and
most of the lords of the north would
probably want to get rid of them too so
tormund Giantsbane and all the wildlings
including the Giants anybody that came
south of the wall they're next on the
hit list but you go further south you
have Sansa reek the Bolton's in Brienne
all running around chasing each other as
we've seen the trailer Sansa and reek
are still on the run there's even a
scene where we see them crossing a big
stream it's just part of the process of
Sansa shedding that sweet summer child
persona like she's been drug through the
mud she's literally getting drugged
through a frozen river here she's gonna
be this battle-hardened person we see
later in the trailer as we see later
here though Davos looks like he's
talking to Sansa so it looks like he's
gonna be doing a version of what he does
in the books so Stannis is still alive
in the books on the show it seems like
he's dead in both cases he was building
an army to get rid of the Bolton's he
had tasks or Davos with adding to the
ranks so sir Davos had been riding all
over the north trying to win more men
for Stannis's army so it looks like for
a big part of this season he'll be doing
that for Sansa because he's riding with
her army here a lot of you have asked
which houses in the north are gonna
support Sansa which houses are gonna
support the Bolton's because it looks
like the Bolton's have a really large
army with a lot of different banners so
we don't know exactly how many houses
they're gonna do on the show there are
47 different houses just in the north
alone there's no way the show is gonna
do all of them I'm expecting maybe like
10 or 15 when we actually get to those
episodes we'll have to count all the
banners usually that's the easiest way
to do it little further south you have
Bear Island where it actually looks like
Sansa is right here ancestral home of
Jorah Mormont and JE or more meant the
old bear the current leader of house
Mormon is mage Mormon the sister of the
old bear but there was that funny moment
during season 5 where Stannis got this
letter from House Mormon giving him the
finger
it was Lyanna Mormont who's like a 10
year old girl that was like there's only
one Lord in the north and his name is
Stark so we'll probably it
see that little girl even if we don't
see mage Mormon but pretty easy to guess
that they're gonna be stark loyalists
the other row big houses the north I'm
pretty sure we're gonna see are the
Karstarks because we've already seen
them the embers and of course the
Bolton's but they'll be more than that
we'll just have to wait to count the
banners when we actually see the armies
lined up
what about Brienne and Podrick though
last seen in the North killing Stannis
so at some point in the trailer we see
them way down further south in Riverrun
was you know we see the totally fish
here that's a long ways to travel so it
remains to be seen what takes her there
because technically she's still on a
mission for the crown to save the
surviving stark girls Jaime gave her her
armor gave her oath keeper said find the
stark girls help them out so whatever
she's doing here she is talking to the
surviving Tully so we'll probably see
blackfish again but to get there she's
gonna have to go past the twins and we
know we see the phrase in the trailer
we're gonna see Walder Frey we're gonna
see Lannisters hanging out with them
what I'm hoping we get is a reverse
version of the red wedding just you know
some revenge against the phrase because
Walder Frey is one of the worst human
beings in Westeros but what about the
Eyrie in the Vale Littlefinger still has
control the idea that he had during
season five is that he was going to play
the Bolton's against the crown and try
and build an army to take them out and
combine his forces from the Eyrie with
that so Littlefinger is still doing that
he's still trying to play the crown
against the Bolton's we see him up here
in the north so eventually it looks like
he'll run it to Sansa again she's
probably gonna be really pissed because
they actually said the writers actually
said he had no idea that Ramsay was a
psychopath so he is currently on her
[ __ ] list over here on the left we have
the Iron Islands didn't see a whole lot
of them during season five but we
finally have euron greyjoy
he's one of Balon Greyjoy's younger
brothers we see Theon's sister here it
looks like there's gonna be a power
struggle because it seems like they're
gonna do a version of the Kingsmoot even
though we're not getting every single
Greyjoy character from the books we
haven't seen Victarion yet that doesn't
mean the show isn't gonna do him he's
another one of ballons brothers but get
really excited because you're on is just
like one of the newest most interesting
characters that George our Martin has
introduced in the books in the last two
books he's one of the few characters
that you don't really meet till way
later in the story going way back over
here to the salt pans ian mcshane all
the stuff that he was talking about
about how he brings back a character all
probably going to be happening here
I won't say what character that is but I
feel like most of you at least have
you've read the books know exactly who
that is so there's gonna be more than
one character that you thought was gone
forever that's probably coming back to
this season I know a lot of the tension
is about Jon Snow like is Jon Snow gone
for good is he coming back there are
other really cool characters that are
totally coming back but that reminds me
Brotherhood without banners also
supposed to show up in some form they
were last seen near the crossroads so
there another Riverlands based storyline
but Thoreau Samir if he comes back
doesn't necessarily guarantee Lady
Stoneheart but I do think that he is
coming back but he was still alive the
last time we saw him they just didn't
use him last season moving down to
King's Landing most of this you've seen
in the trailer Cersei just escaped the
faith by confessing to her sins she
faces trial now that just remains to be
seen how that's gonna play out
she has Sir Robert strong zombie
Mountain protecting her
based on the way she's presented in the
trailer it kind of seems like she thinks
that she's done with this the minute
they come for her and try to drag her to
trial it seems like she's just gonna
stick the mountain on them so it remains
to be seen whether will actually see a
real trial or if it will just come to
blows before that because you see the
faith militant circling around Jaime in
the Sept here so they've just been
teasing a big battle between the faith
like an actual stabby battle in the
streets between the faith the crown and
the Tyrells this is a Tyrell army
marching in behind Jaime here at the
Sept we know from the trailer that they
still have Margaery and Loras who are
still kind of cowering in their own
filth
inside the cells so they're headed for a
war in the streets the same way you see
like the wildlings and Sansa's army
facing up with a Bolton army in the
north
further south he hasn't got there yet
but you have old town you have the
Citadel you have Sam wills family
Samwell and Gilly are still on the ship
in the trailer but that's where they're
headed to the Citadel so Samwell can
learn to become a maester hopefully
he'll gain knowledge in how to fight the
White Walkers
he's on a less magical version of the
Ark that bran is on getting great
knowledge great power if you want to say
knowledge is power you could also say
that Samwell is probably gonna be pretty
powerful too but the difference is bran
will have actual magical powers further
south and Dorne we see ol arias and they
will address what's going on with the
Martellus even if they're not the
biggest part of the season the last we
saw of them they had poisoned Marcella
as Jamie was sailing away back to King's
Landing so they're just gonna follow up
on that moving to the east now or way
down in slavers Bay
tenaris right now is stuck in the
Dothraki sea Tyrion and her small
Council are still in marine so they both
have their own problems they have to
deal with Daenerys has to deal with the
Dothraki now because the biggest thing
for her is that she's been almost
invincible for the last couple of
seasons she's had a big army at her back
she's had dragons
she still has drogon because we see him
in the trailer here but she doesn't have
the army at her back so she has to learn
to win over the Dothraki somehow and it
sounds like they do not give a [ __ ]
about her but we've actually learned
that this Dothraki here is actually not
Khal jhaqo he's actually a different
character that was part of Khal Drogo's
khalasar he was just like a high-ranking
member of his khalasar who has come to
power in Drogo's absence so he'll
remember Daenerys she has to form an
alliance with him somehow because you
have all these people at some point
Daenerys will have to add them to her
army but there will be Dothraki that
remembered Daenerys marinas gonna be
really interesting because Tyrion will
be drinking and knowing things he's
talking about dragon lore in the trailer
we still see the harpies running around
so they'll have an internal revolt that
they still have to deal with what I'm
really hoping is is that Tyrion as he
says you know dragons don't do well in
captivity in the trailer I'm hoping he
releases the Dragons in the Dragons take
care of the harpies but the problem with
that is they can't really control the
dragons they're not bonded to the
dragons in the wait Daenerys is so it's
kind of like him using wildfire during
season two you can use it and it's very
effective but there'll be a lot of
collateral damage if you remember that
scene during Blackwater we're tearing
just unleashes the Wildfire and it works
perfectly but he has that look on his
face like oh my god what have I done I'm
expecting him to do a version of that
with the dragons in the pyramid this
season like oh my god what have I done
slavers Bay is just a big problem in
general so slavery is still a big
problem Daenerys is going to have to win
over the Dothraki and unite the east
before she can come to Westeros there's
still a whole lot of problems and that's
to say nothing of what's happening way
further in the northeast up here in
Braavos you have the iron bank and you
have Arya's faceless men's storyline
those are like the two big things going
on the crown is still deeply in debt to
the iron bank that's why they sent mace
Tyrell and Meryn Trant there in season
five find a way to get rid of some of
the debt to the iron bank so the iron
bank not real big fans of the crown and
also remember they loaned a whole bunch
of money to stand us which basically end
up getting pissed away so
iron bank generally just probably hates
most of Westeros would not be surprised
at all if they then turned around and
offered to fund Daenerys his campaign
look you take Westeros pay us back the
money we are owed arias storyline is
pretty straightforward she has to learn
to survive without the use of her sight
just become a total badass badass Arya
ninja season six but I believe that's
most of the big storylines I'm sure
there's still a couple big questions you
guys have about certain characters or
you know predictions about where things
are headed dan and Dave have said they
have like a solid 10 to 15 hours left of
story to tell which is why you know
there's been a lot of talk about them
shortening the last two seasons they
just confirmed they're gonna do season
seven but HBO did not say how many
episodes would be in season seven they
just said that it was picked up for
season seven so they're still figuring
that out they might make that
announcement after season six is done
because they want most people to focus
on season six
they don't want everyone to be worried
about what's gonna be happening after
but let me know in the comments which of
these storylines are you most excited
about what's going on with Daenerys in
the east what's happening in the north
or what's happening for their south and
your King's Landing those are really
like the three big hotspots even though
there are a lot more storylines that are
actually going on but the important
stuff Game of Thrones Sunday night
episode one if you've been watching it
the last couple of seasons I just I
recommend you know wherever you live in
the world use whatever method you've
been using to wash it to watch it this
season if you have HBO now or like a
streaming option you can use that the
thing about HBO now that's different
from HBO GO is that I think you have to
wait like an hour after it airs on TV to
watch it on HBO go HBO now let you watch
it immediately the minute it drops so
you don't have to wait no matter what
time zone you're in but the thing is is
that even if you subscribe to the HBO
channel you still have to pay for HBO
now I think it's like 14 bucks a month
or 15 bucks but they do have a 30-day
trial so you can sign up for like the 30
day trial
watch the first couple of episodes of
Game of Thrones and then just bail out
if you don't want to pay for it so
however you watch it I'll be posting my
videos after the episodes air so they'll
be available Sunday nights be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I do a weekly giveaway I'll be doing
bonus videos on Sundays this is kind of
my bonus video for this week so my next
game of Thrones video will be that
episode 1 video but the week after that
it'll be like a bonus topic so I'll be
talking about the long night White
Walkers anything you guys want anything
that's interesting and relevant to
what's going on during the season so I
will go
and start the new round of the giveaway
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video this real simple I announced the
winner whenever I post my Q&A videos
that'll be on Monday
typically the Q&A videos are just you
know for answering like the biggest
questions that everyone has or if
there's anything that I missed during
episode one but it's gonna be a really
fun season I don't think it's gonna go
quite as off-book as people think it is
they're circling back around and
grabbing a couple of storylines from
books four and five that they skipped in
previous seasons but there will be a
couple things where they'll push forward
Jon Snow and Daenerys are good examples
of two characters that have already
exhausted their book storyline so
they'll be going to new territory so
whenever we get to that stuff I'll just
I'll mention if they're doing a
storyline from the books or if it's
something that's totally new it's gonna
be a lot of fun and I try to assume that
not everybody's read the book so I will
try to be pretty careful about how I
mentioned book stuff while you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here or here for the last big game of
Thrones trailers thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you